i might i may have to switch to my
laptop at some point but all right it
should be fine now
okay so i wasn't talking [ __ ] about the
stonewall per se
um i've actually played the sono i was
talking [ __ ] about you playing
you playing the stonewall so
that is my identity that is my chess
career how
dare you
[Music]
i had a feeling that that might where's
levy i'm hanging up
where's levi the savior well here's the
let me explain
a little bit of my rationale okay
and so first of all maybe i can
interrogate a little bit about your
sort of chess upbringing so how long
have you been playing
and when did you learn the story so how
can you give me a little bit of a sense
of
how you've progressed thus far not
not well uh i started playing chess
this summer because of pog champs or the
end of the summer
and i learned i learned the stonewall
because
levy taught it to me and it was the only
thing i seem to remember
and then we've gone from there and
apparently levy taught me the stonewall
wrong and i didn't realize until i
re-watched his video on youtube where he
re-taught it differently
so i've been kind of doing it
differently that's so we call it the
cutie wall
it's pretty good interesting okay and
and what's your rating currently
uh 8.72 okay so you've been playing
rocks just since the summer uh-huh
perfect perfect
so do you feel that like at this point
in your chest development is there sort
of a specific area that you've been
struggling in or
uh do you feel like there's something
you want immediate instruction on or is
it sort of an overall
assessment that you're looking for uh
overall
but also i'm i'm really bad with black
pieces okay really really bad and it
makes me very angry
and um i i'm bad at like
discovered checks okay
discovered uh yeah i just like don't see
them
and i don't use them correctly
interesting
okay so discover checks black pieces
openings of the black pieces
yeah particularly against d4 what do you
play against e4
right now uh
i just do the stonewall okay
so can we make an analysis board can i
invite you to it
because as far as i remember there's no
stonewall against
one e4 i mean you could play the stone
wall but you might get checkmated in
convolution yeah i'll usually do it
incorrectly and i'll just start making a
stone wall
okay we will solve this problem asap i
am a
mercenary that okay let me make an
analysis board and then i'll invite you
to it at some
point my headphones run out of battery
and i will connect new ones
so i will stop hearing you at at some
point in the next like 15 minutes for
like
30 seconds i wonder what your chat
thinks of are you just qt cinderella in
the uh oh i need to go
live okay just go to life chess
i think there's an inverse correlation
as you've already figured out between
competence in every stage
and field of life and chess and it's a
strict reverse uh inverse correlation
all right what did you just say no
there's a there's an inverse
relationship between how good you are at
chess
and how good you are at everything else
so when your chest gets better
everything suffers my friend did not
comprehend that
i was like i'm not processing
okay so since i'm so good at life that's
why i'm bad at chess
right exactly well you're not bad at
chess i think you're you're better than
maybe you think but we'll see we'll see
okay my goal is to be better than ludwig
which i know hess does lessons with him
and hess is in my chat
oh he's in my track too he's infested
both of our chats oh my god
yes teach him bad moves so i can beat
him someday
[Music]
little do you know of our the state of
my relationship with the gms
we are mortal enemies okay so let me
know when you're in live chess
okay i'm there and you're a qt
cinderella yep
okay i just invited you see if you got
it
are anything capitalized qt capital and
c capital
uh q yeah the first three letters all
kind of first three letter okay let me
try that
all right just invited you oh got it
okay perfect
yeah okay so e4 what would you play
right now if your next phone played e4
um okay
i guess what i've been doing recently is
copying well yeah
well yeah and then i'll usually build a
stonewall
okay so let's say i go knight on the
wrong side levy did tell me that against
e4 i should never try to do stonewall
but i
have been doing it anyway okay so you've
been playing c5
no i would go d d6 aha so that's called
the philidor defense
nah that is a that is a legitimate
opening but it's it's not particularly
good
and uh the best line here for white is
to play d4 strike in the center
immediately
yeah and then i get stressed out
right i mean this here he white is
already attacking the pawn on e5 so you
kind of have to take
and you can see that white's got more of
the center than you do so we'll get into
like the reasons why that is bad so we
definitely i think should start
would you like for me to teach you a
legitimate opening with black so that we
can kind of solve this problem
so let me give you two different schools
of
approach and by the way you can i think
you can flip my chats tell me you can
flip the board
since we're gonna be looking for black
um the first
is the sort of very conservative
approach where
i can teach you something relatively
easy to learn
and this will get you started and the
main move that beginners play is e4e5
and um that's sort of the standard move
you're copying white is the king spawn
game and after knight f3
the most popular move by far the best
move by far is to play night out to c6
and on a fundamental level why is this
move made because the move knight f3
what does this accomplish
from white's perspective uh to take that
pawn
to take that pawn you were defending the
pawn of the night and simultaneously
developing your pieces the object of the
opening at a basic level
is to develop your pieces actively
toward the center and
are you sort of familiar with those
basic opening principles
yes yes that you should control the
middle as much as possible
okay yes that is not touch the same
pieces as
much as you can right castle as thin as
possible
exactly and um i can teach you
an opening called the sicilian defense
which is the move c5 but what i'm
inclined to show you
is um well should i teach qt i'm asking
my chat if i should teach you the
stafford the stafford gambit what do you
guys think
that'll be a complete experiment um but
it might also also win you a lot of
games
i do love gambits okay seem to thrive
off of gambits
so the gambit that i'm going to show you
and uh
i did not absolutely i'm that
i i i have such attention span problems
that i literally have to write this down
i'm writing i'm holding a pen in my hand
so yeah
we are in the same boat here then i
started drawing a flower i shouldn't
have done that
okay i'm done with my flower so this
opening
is a gambit it is going to teach you
a lot about opening principles and in
order to play this opening well
you are going to have to basically show
command of fundamental opening
principles and there is going to be some
stuff that you have to remember
but a lot of it is fun you can win a lot
of games very very fast
and uh just in general i think this is
going to contribute to your chess
development
love that okay okay so after knight f3
you play the move knight to f6 this in
and of itself is called the russian game
or the petrov
and being russian i'm that completely
does not influence my choice now knight
c6 is most common
the move that you will be playing is
knight to f6
okay why does this seem odd what can
white do in this position
because then you just trade pawns with
your knights right
and speaking of discover checks here's
an early exercise
in in finding discovered checks so if
you take this pawn on e4
white can deploy the queen to e2 right
and he
attacks your knight what happens if you
just drop the knight back to six can you
find
white's best move here
um isn't it
is it is it f7
because then he makes the king move so
first of all let's break this down yeah
i'm i'm i'd be in check
right you're so i i mean as white you're
playing white here
and uh i'm showing you this opening for
black but just for a second i want you
to find white's best move
okay and uh you do notice this
my arrow that i'm drawing what am i
referring to here the queen and the king
how do you define that what is that
um i don't know what it's supposed to be
called but i call that like a
like a row yeah like they're on the same
row i would call that an x-ray so when a
piece
stares at the king through another piece
so you have two white pieces and a black
face you have a black king
a white queen and then there's a white
knight in between the queen and the king
on the same file
does that construction make sense yes
so that is the precursor to a discovered
check
a discover check is when you move that
middle piece out of the way and then the
queen is going to be tracking the king
right
so let's think logically where you want
to move this knight
when you move this knight you can move
it back to f3 for all you care and
that's check
is this a particularly effective check
is what can black do here to cover this
check
uh he can move his bishop or his
queen and which one would you move uh
my queen or the bishop absolutely why
that's correct because then if he takes
it i still have a queen
right if white takes the bishop then you
have a free queen but also in the name
of developing as fast as possible you
see this queen on e2
it's very poorly placed can you tell me
why from the perspective of developing
pieces which pieces of blocking
uh it's bishop exactly and if your king
gets stuck in the center and i want i
want you to like hammer this
into your brain this is a fundamental
opening principle if your king gets
stuck in the center of the board
it's going to get in trouble you want to
castle more often than not
as quickly as possible and this bishop
not being developed is preventing white
from castling anyways
so in this position you want to move the
knight and deliver check to black's king
but if you're moving the knight then you
might as well move it to a square where
it is attacking an enemy piece
because black is going to have to attend
to the check and then that knight is
going to be able to capture whatever
piece it threatens
so where would you move the knight now
that you've sort of understood the logic
behind the discover check where would
you move the knight
you want to inflict maximum damage to
black's most valuable piece
[Music]
take your time okay let me map this out
zero rush
that's a good idea noticing all of the
squares knight in the center controls
eight squares that's
by the way why you want to put pieces in
the center they control most amount of
squares
oh uh uh
is it just is it just this one
very close that's the second bed that's
a b plus move and then i have to cover
the check and what do you do with the
knife
i take the rook excellent but you can
actually win the queen
you have the exact exactly the right
logic but where can you put the knight
to it
bingo i saw the other night and i was
like that'll take it and i totally
forgot
exactly and if there wasn't a queen to
attack then you would attack the rook so
discovered checks give you like
a you know credit card with an unlimited
uh you know roof you can just spend
whatever you want to do because the
queen is checking the black king
that's the check that i have to take
care of and now you take the queen of
course if i cover with my queen then
what happens
uh i take the queen anyway you take the
queen anyway
now could you could you answer this
final question before we move on could
you play knight take step seven and sign
and also take a pawn and then take the
queen
or would that not work uh
that wouldn't work because the king
would take the knight the king would
take the knight that's what you have to
be careful when you're giving a discover
check you want to make sure that the
piece that the king that's being checked
isn't also taking uh the piece that's
doing the
the discovering is does that make sense
repeat so when you are giving a discover
check
there is a piece that's sort of doing
the discovering and i would say that
that's the knight
that's the night then there's the peace
he is our he's our sacagawea
yes he's the sack of joy and the queen
is is louis and or clark
well if you please and uh you want to
make sure that the king
cannot capture sacagawea and escape
lewis and clark if that makes sense
yes and um
you know however you want to you know
visualize the queen and the knights
uh when you move the knight it's a
standalone unit so the king
if you take on d7 for example can
capture the knights
or if you take on f7 it can also capture
the knight that's the one thing you want
to avoid with discovered checks
lame yeah okay so that makes sense right
yep okay we'll practice discover checks
a lot more and i'll show you how to
practice them on your own
but for the time being let's let's focus
on the opening
now your opponents are usually going to
make one of two moves in this position
i'm i'm black again
you are you're black now flip the board
now we're talking about the opening
theory
so i'm ready uh some of your opponents
are going to
move the other knight out to c3 this
defends the pawn on e4
and in the event of that you are also
going to develop your knife this is
called
believe it or not chess players are very
original drum roll please the four
knights game
oh yeah you would never believe why that
is right
yeah geniuses very creative
and let's very briefly review the ladies
those chests oh yeah
no i mean their naming that itself
already makes them yeah
their tinder profiles get just yeah i
mean
you will not believe the number of
matches yeah
totally so essentially your task
and i want to talk with talk through
basically the way that you want to
develop your pieces so let's say that i
as white play bishop c4 now you want to
develop your bishop on f8 where do you
want to develop it
uh c5
exactly and it aims toward f2 i'm going
to play d3
continue with black
castle castle is not a bad move
but it is more flexible and i'll explain
to you why in a second to play the move
d6 it's a little bit more tricky to copy
white
this looks like a stone wall almost well
you've got the like pawn chain here
so i i can see some elements i almost
have my cup
yeah i see so you're close enough to
your comfort zone where
this isn't too repulsive yet it's bad
because then i'll get
confused i'll get i'll be like wait a
second
this is awesome if if i do a good job
then i'll teach it to you in such a way
that you'll understand the principles
behind these moves and so you'll be able
to find them
now basically here's the thing let's say
that white castles
now instead of castling you have an even
better move this move
sets up a pin what move am i talking
about
queen and where should you move and
which piece should you move
my queen should move up to
uh d7 okay and how is that a pin
[ __ ] it's not not only is it not a pin
but here's what you're doing
this freaking this bishop right here
it's
seriously complaining because it can't
get out
is that good that is a [ __ ] terrible
thing
that's right bishop g4 is the move now
does this pin
and the concept of a pin you're fully
comfortable with right
yes okay so the bishop they always just
do this
excellent so you have a choice here they
attack your bishop
and you can either take the knight or
you can drop the bishop back to h5
intuitively which of these two moves
does your gut tell you to play
that i should drop back exactly and if
you had to explain why
why would you drop back and not take the
knight honestly
the biggest reason is because levy said
i have to stop
playing like a crazy person okay so
let's start with the fact pins are good
okay
now pins are good because they
essentially
make a piece that is pinned unable to
move the knight cannot move
why because then i'll get the queen for
free
then you'll get the queen for free now
is it always the case that a pin piece
can't move
no because maybe you could imagine that
the knight could move and threaten
checkmate
but that situation is very very rare and
i could show you a situation where
a pinned piece actually can move but
that's not important right now
pins are good 95 of the time and so
by taking on f3 you are helping white
get rid of the pin you're giving up that
very same bishop
which was pinning the knight so what is
white going to take back with
the queen but let's say that you had
taken on f3 can you
can you spot a good move that attacks
this queen and activates one of your
pieces
uh the knight my knight on the c file
very good where could it go uh d4
exactly so even if you take on f3 your
position isn't terrible
uh but you could make this move knight
t4 to activate your knight but yes you
should drop the bishop back to preserve
the pin
okay so um white has two ways of dealing
with this situation he can either try to
chase your bishop away even further with
g4 yeah
and here i'm going to teach you a pretty
cool response i don't know if you've
ever
ran across i've had that happen
okay you're going to [ __ ] people up in
in this line in just a second
just bursting with excitement we love
ruining lives oh absolutely
and the second thing that white can do
is like some sort of neutral
neutral movement we were we're watching
you're
you're watching my wife we've been
watching your like road to 3000.
and it was so sad because you were like
playing at 800 and you had 30 seconds
left and you're like chat relax it
doesn't matter i'm gonna beat him anyway
and i was like
that's so sad that poor 800 is probably
like there's a chance there's a chance
he's gonna run at a time
especially because i've been so i've
been so slow the entire game and then
all of a sudden
yeah that's so sad i would cry
anyway i'm i'm a horrible bastard you're
being taught by a heartless bastard so
full disclosure i thrive off this energy
excellent so the second idea that white
can play is just a move like bishop d2
now you have this pin right
do you know how to exploit this one how
do you layer on the pressure on this f3
now you have a particular move
you just found this move in a different
context let's say the night again
okay what is your idea let's let's make
a random move for white how are you
going to continue now
i'm going to take that night with what
with my other knight
exactly why not with the bishop because
uh my bishop is what's
staring at that queen exactly it'll get
taken by that pawn and then i take it
wait a second no that doesn't work well
which what you want to do here
so you can because then he's in check
wait i don't know actually
yeah so if you take with a bishop or if
you take with a knight white's response
is going to be the same
white has to recapture whatever piece it
is that you capture on f3 with
and what is the con why is this good for
white for uh black just logically
can you explain that to me uh
what have you achieved as a result of
this trade i have opened his file
on the king and he has stacked pawns yes
he has very weak pawns all over the king
and weak pawns like these are very very
important when they're located next to
the king because that presents to you a
a very clear pathway toward checkmating
the king
um so now in terms of whether you would
take with the bishop over the knight the
reason i like taking with the knight
is because after g takes f3 what is this
pawn
what is this once again what is this
called
yes the pawn is pinned which means the
pawn cannot move which means the pawn
cannot help this queen on d1 his queen
get involved in the defense
last thing in this position i want you
to involve your queen
in the attack i want you to bring it to
the square that i'm about to highlight
in blue
how do you get your queen there in the
fastest possible way
i moved my my other knight my f knight
where would you move it
in order for it to be least disruptive
yep very good oh okay oh yeah
among the squares you highlighted was
the correct square
so this is how i see unfortunately no
this is all good
i would uh this is the only safe one
excellent yep knight d7 and then you
bring the queen out to h1 now does it
make sense to you intuitively that the
queen
is oftentimes the strongest attacker
because it is the strongest piece
and uh once you bring the queen to h4
you want to just [ __ ] him up here queen
takes h3 bishop takes f3 we'll talk
about the nitty-gritty later
but for now that's enough in this slide
okay yeah so
it seems to me that you're comfortable
developing your pieces to active squares
you just need to be confident in doing
so
yeah and you need to react dynamically
to what white does so for example let's
say that in this position
the bastard that play playing white goes
h3 now
tell me where you would want to develop
this bishop on c8
and here comes my head i need to change
my headset now so
that moment has arrived give me one
second
all right this is a complex procedure
where i
all right one moment
here we go
all right
i think i can hear you know why not
yes i can hear you yeah perfect
deeply at this uh
so uh this bishop where do you put it
i could only go to e6 safely
kind of e6 offers a what what can
potential trade bingo now maybe probably
let me just tell you this but
every time there's a potential trade
there's two things that there's a
checklist that you need to go through
item number one is is the piece that
i'm offering more valuable than the
piece my opponent is
going to be offering that would
constitute a blunder okay so if you put
a rook on e6
the bishop is more valuable than the
rook unless you're sacrificing that
piece deliberately
which is possible uh that is not
advisable
so the piece that you're offering should
be of the same value the piece your
opponent is offering right
that is an obvious point but just making
sure that we're on board with that
number two
is you need to make sure that the trade
gives you
something specific you make specific
gains in the position
okay so i can give you an example of a
good trade or i can give you an example
of a battery does the trade
give you new stuff for your pieces and
we'll put that into context in just a
second okay
and this has to happen basically every
time that a potential trade is on the
cards you have to quickly run through
these two items
okay now in this case as a result of the
trade
could you tell me what black gains and
if black has any new defects in the
position
good stuff and bad stuff that happens
uh bad stuff is i have stacked pawns
excellent that's the only bad thing but
that's not a
very bad thing stack puns are not great
but they're not horrible
okay how about the good stuff good thing
i have even more control of the center
excellent you have this pawn controls
this square very good
and if i if i castle on that side
i won't get back if you castle you will
not get back ringing that easily that is
something i
didn't even notice but that is
absolutely true and there's one other
thing that is true
about you castling what now do you have
for this rook
oh a free a free file call row column
yeah
exactly this is a file by the way and
this is a rank
these are ranks yep exactly but you can
i'll understand
yeah row and yeah okay so this is the f
file
and this is the eighth rank so
this is what b file
very good this for rank
yeah fourth rank that's exactly right so
you get essentially the f file for your
rook
and you could imagine a scenario where
the rook basically [ __ ] him up on one
of these
squares i'm not saying this is going to
happen on this move but this is exactly
what the essence of chess is you want
your pieces to be as active as possible
and what it means to be active is to be
controlling squares and to be poised in
a position where you can essentially
mess your opponent up
should the opportunity present itself
okay
okay so that's a rundown of
of this line and i'm glad that you were
able to see bishop e6 you don't want to
stubbornly put your bishop here
regardless of what they do
we'll get back to this in a moment but
let's talk about the scenario where they
take your knight on e5 where they take
your pawn and e5
here's the slightly mind-boggling thing
uh can you remind me why this move is
bad
um
oh god i already forgot it's okay
why is this bad and remember discover
check
you try to remember the final position
of this line with that knight sitting on
c6 and winning black screen and i think
i guarantee you
you'll remember the first move that sets
this thing up for white
i thought the queen was involved why am
i it was queen involve it
involve white's queen you're now playing
light by the way so oh okay let me flip
the board that's probably why yep
you'll see it immediately queen oh yeah
i just bring my
right exactly and if i move my knight
away
then i get to do my cool thing excellent
and now you saw knight c6 and you win
the queen
yeah now one more thing before i stop
bothering you about this position
let's say that as as black i say wait
wait i'm not moving my knight from e4
i'm going to defend that knight
with the move d5 you're still playing
white
try to follow this up
okay i'm still playing white try to
follow this up
yes guys i do cuss occasionally when i
do these collab streams
um it's also 2 a.m so i hope no
seven-year-olds are watching
the stream uh would i uh but sorry about
that guys that's just
how i do it uh so yeah you and what
would be the idea
to uh put your pressure on his knight
to attack the knight so putting pressure
is to sort of bother something but d3
literally
threatens the net now between these two
moves which one is less weakening in
terms of your own king
um d because i'm gonna castle on
on the other side yes and also because
the move f3
creates a weakness along this diagonal
black can give you this very nasty check
potentially
okay okay so the move
the move f3 in general there's a running
joke among chess players which by
definition means it's not funny at all
but the joke says never play and never
play f3 there are some funny chess jokes
but
they're like buried under under like a
cloud of rubble so never play f3 and the
reason this this is said
is because this weakens very
significantly the king's side
yeah d3 and if the knight moves then
can you still do what you did previously
uh sorry i'm writing that down i'm
writing down never play f3 yes i can
i can do that you absolutely can the
fact that black has played this doesn't
really change anything about this move
like black now has an additional escape
score for the king but it doesn't
actually matter
because you just take the queen great so
now that you're on board with
why black antique let's take a look at
the correct move you can flip the board
back to face
black the move is knight to c6
you develop the other knight now
what do you feel like is white's most
tempting move
like what seems to be the the obvious
move that white has in this position
the tempting move from white yes and
this is the move
99.9 of people are gonna play against
you is that bishop
oh wait no you can actually make the
movie if you'd like
uh no that's it yeah yeah because they
love looking at that f7s
okay well that would be a blunder due to
what response
this move knight c6 impacts the knight
on e5 it threatens it
it offers a trick which means that if
they do not respond to the trade what
are you gonna do
i take it yeah you just take the knight
and that's an extra piece
that is literally just an extra piece
for black oh
so but does that make sense well it's an
unfamiliar position you're just not used
to things being hanging this early so
that's totally understandable okay so he
came here thinking
i would trade but instead i went here he
would
notice that and do what about it
okay he would beginners are offered a
trade they usually accept it
that's just rule of chess basically yeah
so now
i think he would just oh well they would
trade i think
what does that mean they would go take
your night they would take your night
now
i want you to tell me i'm not even going
to tell you the move i want you to find
it based on principles you have two
recaptures
you can take with this bun or you can
take with this one based on opening
principles which pawn would you take
with
b final answer uh
why wait did you say er
i did what why be what
what was the rash what was the logic
behind this because i'm castling on the
other side
okay but wait a second if you take with
the towards the center
so capture toward the center is a rule
okay but that's not something that
should really influence your decision
that much instead could you tell me what
the main advantage of the move dc is in
terms of development
well now my queen has an open file a and
b
what else has an open diagonal
oh my bishop your bishop
your bishop on c8 now has an open
diagonal that doesn't mean
when i say this that doesn't mean that
you are going to move this bishop on the
next move it just means you have the
capacity to do that
soon and the idea behind almost
any gambit is that you get a lead in
what
pieces which translates to development
right but basically you're right i mean
development
fundamentally you're right you get a
lead in pieces being active
and that's exactly what you put an
emphasis on here and
the reason that white loses games really
faster is because
when you start developing your pieces
you start creating threats
and when you start creating threats if
white doesn't develop in exactly the
right way
then he's going to get absolutely
blasted here so
what do you think white is going to do
here
what do you think white is going to do
here i think white
is going to
[Music]
i think naturally they would bring out
their bishop
they would bring out their bishop and
where would they put it uh
now now now they would go c4
okay so let's start by looking at this
move if you are down to put some time
into this position you will know this
position
better than anybody within 600 points of
you
and this will bring you some wins so and
by the way i know it's late so at any
point if you want to pause i'm
i don't want to take it out you're
totally fine in time i appreciate it i'm
a night bird
yeah okay good okay good and um
okay so in bishop c4 now you actually
can take
the pawn on e4 now
obviously you should be surprised here
like you should be surprised because
queenie2
creates what against the night remind me
what this is oh
a discovered check a pin
a pin this is a pin and it's called i
think an absolute pin by some people
because the night literally cannot move
it is illegal for the night to move
and uh it appears that the knight may be
lost but
how can you save the knights and and get
rid of the pin at the same time
save the knight and get rid of the pin
at the same time
uh just by moving my queen up to east
excellent you bring your queen up to e7
nicely done
and um if white now uh attacks your
knight with d3
can you move the knight
uh yes
yes you can move it to d6 in order to
put pressure on the bishop and what is
possible now what are you offering here
a trade with the queen a trade of queens
and uh that trade of queens what will
you take on e7 with the bishop of the
king
the bishop the bishop in order to
continue your development this is an end
game black is doing very well here
notice that you have won back the pawn
you've sacrificed at some point we will
take a look at this this is not
uh particularly likely i think that most
people that you face
are actually not going to give up this
pawn in my opinion i think and we will
see i mean if you are down to play this
then at some point we are going to see
what people actually do here
okay and my guess is that people are
going to try to defend this pawn in one
of
three ways could you give me one way to
defend the pawn on e4
and develop a piece at the same time
um pulling out their pawns
on d2 or f2
yes so they can play the move d3 they
can play the move f3 although
as we discussed that is not very
advisable because it weakens the king
very severely
right but how can they develop a piece
and simultaneously defend the pawn
the queen but developing the queen
is not usually an essential goal of the
night the night
and where would you put it on c3
very good so knight c3 is the move that
i believe is most common
among beginners because they are taught
to develop their pieces and they
simultaneously defend the plan
yes now the great thing about this is
called the stafford gambit the great
thing about the stafford gamut is that
your play is extremely natural you make
moves that you should be able to come up
with yourself
even if you forget what i taught you
and uh this starts with the bishop on f8
find me the most active square for that
bishop
what is the most active square but that
bishop
most is uh
d6 why because
uh uh
because it's it's in the middle it's in
the middle but
the middle is is very wide the middle is
here
even here you should be less okay so
here's what i want you to
think less about a piece being literally
in the middle
and about what a piece is doing you want
a piece to be specific i want to point
to a piece and you say this is what that
piece is doing
so the knight on f6 what is it doing it
is threatening this pawn putting
pressure on the pawn and it's
obviously controlling squares i mean
controlling squares is already a job for
a piece
uh so don't take this like too far but
if you put the bishop on d6
it's not this pawn on h does this pawn
seem significant to you where is white's
king
no white's king is still there over here
so can you put the bishop on a square so
that it aims at upon
near white's king yes so then it's c5
excellent now if white's king were to be
castled
then and only then would it be more
sensible to develop the bishop to d6
because what would be the difference the
king would be on
g1 so then if i took that pawn i'd be
looking at it yeah
exactly so potentially you would be
pressuring a pawn that is nearby the
king
pawns in and of themselves are not that
significant it's the pawns that are near
the king
which give you that avenue that you can
use to approach the king
so bishop c5 is the move okay okay so
bishop c5 is the move
and uh let's say that white continues to
play kind of
nonchalantly and i can show you how
quickly white can get a lost position if
white plays the move d3
white is already lost and notice this
pawn
can you find another way to attack this
pawn with another piece
that's your position well
yep but then his queen but look at the
whole board is that knight going to be
protected
that's why you played d take c6
yep exactly the bishop is going to the
bishop's going to protect the knights so
can you make them move on the board
yes excellent now you see that you're
threatening to take on f2 what are you
threatening to take with
the knight of the bishop let's say that
white ghost h3
you can take either with the bishop with
check or with the knight which one would
you take with
take with the bishop why
oh god though i take with the knight
because then i get a fork
you've got a fork on the king queen and
the rook good good recognition of forks
the only reason
that you would take with the bishop
would be if this were like checkmate
and this is very clearly not checkmate
in fact this leads to a very problematic
situation i'm going to give you another
trick question
is white threatening to take the knight
in this position let's say you make the
wrong move
do you need to move the knight no
because then my bishop will put him in
check again
and and why is that bad for white like
let's say that
i don't know you play a random move and
then white takes the knight
in your head if you take with the bishop
and white takes this bishop on f2 isn't
white winning two pieces
no because i get his queen excellent
that's what i wanted you to see what i
want you to notice here is that the king
and the queen are on the same diagonal
and what you're gonna have to do as you
start getting better is making these
observations when you see a position in
which ah
the king and the queen are on the same
diagonal so what kind of a tactic
uh does that sort of give rise to in
certain positions
okay that's a question
oh i was writing it down
no worries um
yes okay uh
when you've got like a situation like
this king and the queen are the same
diagonal
there's two related related tactics that
are kind of the reverses of each other
it's not removed the defender no that's
a different different area different
ballpark different
so what is this called if you play
bishop takes g4 check
what is the name of this that's called
check
that is called check but the specific
tactical pattern is called a skewer
have you heard of a skewer oh yes a
skewer this is a skewer now if you flip
the position of the of the um king and
the queen what would that be called
that would be called a opposite of a
skewer when the pieces are
flipped and you know this
that is called an oh [ __ ] that is is
called also an oh [ __ ] for the opponent
who utters that or
utters that uh that's a pin that is a
pin
so in your mind whenever a king and the
queen are on the same diagonal or a king
in the rook are on the same diagonal you
want to start looking for pins and
skewers against those pieces
that is how you start seeing tactics if
you don't notice these things then
you're not going to be looking for
the [ __ ] that's going to win you pieces
and win you the game right
okay but here you did notice and
uh well done you notice the fork queen
moves and you play what
i play knight h1
and you are up a rook you're winning a
rook you're going to have to evacuate
this night which is not going to be easy
but you're going to do that with the
help of attacking white's king so let's
say that i play the move g
to g2 to g4 what is the purpose of this
move
what is white threatening um to
take the knight with his queen to take
the knight with the screen now
you're you i'm sure uh not because like
you're bad but because that's just how
you know one thinks about chess before
they get experienced
you're probably inclined to move the
night right
uh that's what you're thinking about i i
but that is not the only way to save the
night
look at white's king for a second can
you attack that king
while involving another one of your
pieces into the attack
yes i could bring my bishop up to f2
okay
and that's the right idea but there is a
way to do the exact same thing along
that very diagonal but to bring another
piece into the attack the bishop is
already participating
instead think about your other pieces
which of them could come into the attack
oh my queen could bury h4
excellent queen h4 check that king on e1
and you should already see this
intuitively is in trouble
now in theory would you want to trade
queens here if you're black
did you learn the the sort of one of the
key rules of
of of converting a material advantage
i i learned that
i don't know how true this is but i
learned that you should
um you should always trade your queen
when you're black
so that you it's not that you should
always trade your queen with your black
when you are up material so i would say
when you have an extra rook
or more yeah then trading pieces is
generally a good idea
also known as simplifying the position
the more you trade
like imagine if you have an extra rook
and there's x number of pieces on the
board if you if you trade all of those
pieces you're just gonna have a rook
against the king and are you comfortable
delivering basic checkmates yes so
you're basically trying to
and that should make sense to you trying
to reach that basic checkmate by trading
as many pieces as possible